quatre personnes en capuchonnées prises
en flagrant délit en train de tabasser
un quadragénère pour voler son deux
roues cette scène violence est déroulée
hier soir à Viry-Châtillon dans
l'Essonne près du quartier sensible de
la Grande Borne surpris pendant les
faits par la brigade anti-criminalité de
des malfaiteurs ont été interpellés et
placés en garde à vue suite à plusieurs
faits de vols en bande organisé dans les
environs de Grigny les forces de l'ordre
il y avait mis en place une surveillance
renforcée depuis plusieurs jours ce
mercredi peu après 19h30 les policiers
ont repéré la présence d'un scooter
d'une moto montée par quatre individus
habillés en noir et en capuchonner c'est
devant un feu tricolore que les
individus sont soudainement descendus de
leur cyclomoteur pour attaquer un homme
de 43 ans à l'arrêt sur son deux roues
après l'avoir poussé au sol et lui porte
une série de coups tout en cherchant à
dérober sa moto l'un d'entre eux semble
être muni d'une arme mais la brigade
anti criminalité intervient alors
rapidement poussant les quatre
malfaiteurs à prendre la fuite l'un
d'eux a chuter durant sa course jetant
son arme de poing il s'est rapidement
relevé mais a chuté de nouveau
permettant aux forces de l'ordre de
l'interpeller selon une source policière
le malfaiteur de 19 ans il a été
aussitôt placé en garde à vue ainsi
qu'un deuxième suspect une enquête de
flagrance a été ouverte pour des faits
de tentatives de vol en bande organisée
avec armes Gérald Darmanin le ministre
de l'Intérieur n'a pas tardé à réagir à
ses faits à Grigny comme partout sur le
territoire national les policiers et
singulièrement dans cette affaire ceux
de la brigade anticriminalité
interviennent et interpelle
courageusement pour lutter contre des
délinquants violents et dangereux Fabien
van hemerlik secrétaire général du
syndicat Alliance a pour sa part salué
le travail de la police tout en assurant
qu'il s'agissait de la réalité du
terrain des fonctionnaires bravo à eux
et à tous ceux qui subissent la foudre
au quotidien pour lutter contre la
délinquance le pédopsychiatre Maurice
Berger appelle à réhabiliter le rôle
dissuasif de la justice nous ne pouvons
combattre cette violence que par la
force la force de l'État les victimes et
proportionnées sauf que nous sommes
actuellement dans une société où il y a
une énorme délitimation de toute
utilisation de la force le
pédopsychiatre propose notamment
d'instaurer de courtes peines de prison
seul moyen pour certains de prendre
conscience de la gravité de leurs actes
souvent la sanction la peine c'est le
seul miroir qui permet à des mineurs de
se rendre compte que ce qu'ils ont fait
est grave comment faire poursuivre
compte que c'est grave c'est la lourdeur
de la sanction et on a aussi un certain
nombre de jeunes pas tous qui ne
commencent à penser que quand ils ne
peuvent plus agir
[Musique]